so we have some new leaked photos from
spider-man far from home and these new
photos show us a new Spidey suit it's
different from what we know it's
actually red and black not red and blue
and it's got new web shooters on it this
is the third Spidey suit that we've seen
so far with leaked photos from the set
of spider-man far from home so why are
there so many suits and what does this
mean I'm still giving away copies of
infinity war and ant-man and the loss
all you have to do to enter the giveaway
is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
why are there so many different
spider-man suits in spider-man far from
home well what we know so far from the
leaked photos that we've seen is that
spider-man is actually working with
slash for shield and we've seen happy
Hogan in some of these leaked photos and
videos as well so it's safe to assume
that he's getting all of these suits
from happy slash shield it's clear that
spider-man is going about doing some
missions for a shield and some require
him to be a little bit sneaky which is
why we have seen the stealth suit I
think that this new suit is primarily
for the advanced web shooter although we
don't really know anything about it it
does seem to be a little bit more
embedded in the suit so it probably has
some enhancements on it so spider-man
far from home just wrapped up shooting
in Venice and now they're shooting in
New York City and the curious thing
about all of these leaked photos that
we've seen is that Tony Stark is nowhere
to be found a lot of people are assuming
that he dies in Avengers 4 and that's
why we haven't seen him in any of these
photos but that doesn't necessarily mean
that he dies he could simply retire and
be out of the picture and that's why
he's not in the movie or Marvel could
just be taking extra precautions to make
sure that nobody knows that Tony Stark
will actually be in the movie so they
don't give away any spoilers for
Avengers 4 but here's the thing about
filming a movie something usually gets
out one way or another there are so many
people involved in making a movie there
are so many people that are part of the
crew something usually gets out one way
or another it's really hard to keep
things a secret what usually happens is
that somebody who's on the crew is a
super die-hard fan of the
movie and they go and tell their friend
and their friend leaks it online
this happened with Infinity Ward there
were a lot of leaks that ended up being
true so there have been no reports of
Robert Downey jr. being on set at all
and in the leaked photos and videos that
we've seen it's always been happy Hogan
meeting with Nick Fury and Maria hill
not Tony Stark
so if Tony Stark is not in the picture
anymore happy would most likely run
Stark Industries or at least play a huge
part which is probably why he is dealing
with shield usually Tony Stark would
deal directly with Nick Fury such as
he's always done in the previous films
so there seems to be more and more
evidence that Tony Stark isn't going to
survive Avengers 4 or he's going to
retire and step away from Stark
Industries completely but again just
because we haven't seen him doesn't mean
that any of this is true but let me know
what you all think and let me know what
you think of spider-man's new suit hit
me with your thoughts in the comments
below and don't forget to subscribe
comment and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
with everything related to spider-man
far from home and Avengers 4 as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]